we all know about hunter biden's dirty
deeds but sleepy joe isn't the only top
democrat with a son with some shady
business ties the daily mail reports
that nancy pelosi's son paul pelosi jr
was involved with five separate
companies that were each investigated by
federal agencies including a biofuel
company that defrauded investors another
company that was previously caught up in
an investigation of scam calls that
targeted senior citizens and a medical
company accused of testing drugs on
people without fda authorization but hey
maybe he's just really business savvy
like his mommy and his daddy whose stock
moves are followed by retail traders on
tick tock who are looking to be as rich
as the speaker of the house miranda
devine is a new york post columnist and
fox news contributor and she's here with
us now miranda always great to have you
on you're one of my favorites
we hear so much about hunter biden and
his story is obviously so colorful with
hookers and cocaine and pornography but
now we're hearing about nancy pelosi's
son tell us what he's been up to
well look there is obviously a
corruption problem in washington and
paul pelosi jr who's one of nancy
pelosi's children has obviously been
profiting uh by his involvement in
various companies which all seem to have
come under the
investigations of the fbi and the
justice department for various shady
dealings and uh
most unfortunate for him to have been
propelled into
high positions in some of these
companies um and that the companies have
fallen into disrepute but yet nothing
has happened to him and that really is a
passion that we also saw with hunter
biden and i think um look the difference
i guess here is joe biden
internationalized what has really been a
disease in washington of influence
peddling we've known that for many
decades and joe biden was a past master
of it
in delaware and with his very powerful
positions in the senate and then of
course he internationalized it when he
became vice president now nancy pelosi
we also know um has herself enriched
herself as you just mentioned on these
uh stock picks which were extremely
lucky uh over companies that she had
regulatory authority over so that is
very suspect and
really unfortunate that the speaker of
the house is dabbling in that
yeah it's shady i mean martha stewart
went to jail for that why aren't the
pelosis
well exactly and nancy pelosi when this
was raised in congress came out and said
oh it's a free market and we're entitled
to do what we like they are shameless
the democrats in particular but i mean
republicans are also involved in this um
they're absolutely shameless in their
refusal to be accountable you don't go
into congress to enrich yourself but
this is what so many of these people
have done it's really disgusting and
then to be uh you know
lecturing other countries um about
corruption when you're behaving in the
same or worse fashion i mean
we saw with the bidens and with hunter
biden um joe biden was there in ukraine
uh telling them that they have to do
something about their corruption
problems while out the back door his son
was getting you know millions of dollars
we know whether it be russia or china or
kazakhstan or ukraine
this sort of corruption is commonplace
you don't give the money to the powerful
person you give the money to what in
china are called princelings this is the
sons sometimes daughters of powerful
people of the oligarchs of the the
rulers and uh you give the money to them
because you're wanting to carry favor
with their father or their mother in
pelosi's case
yeah the princelings well miranda every
day we look a little more like china
it's very sad
um again the great miranda devine
thank you for joining me tonight thank
you rachel hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else